il était une fois en corée du sud
il n'y a pas si longtemps un projet de
train léger sur rail un trait qui devait
apporter bonheur et prospérité pour
citoyens de la ville de yongin en
banlieue de séoul
les hommes d'affaires de l'entreprise
qui voulaient construire le train
première que c'était une bonne affaire
il offrir des voyages aux élus et ceux
ci les acceptèrent
mal leur en prit si c'était de la
corruption
il nous aurait poursuivi cette
entreprise c'est bombardier canada et
aux mods arabe
aujourd'hui le trait est presque vide
la ville est criblé de dettes c'est un
gros trip hop au tam qui mangent tous
nos impôts
il était une fois un projet de train
léger sur le nouveau pont champlain
un trait qui devrait apporter le bonheur
et la prospérité aux citoyens de la
région de montréal
un projet qui pendant des années a été
conçu sur mesure pour bombardier et snc
lavalin un projet qui concerne
maintenant tous les contribuables et les
épargnants du québec
il répète l'opération matins et soirs du
lundi au vendredi
chaque jour que nous dizaine d'employés
installe l'icône de la voie réservée aux
autobus sur le pont champlain
ça ne devait être qu'un projet pilote en
mais trente six ans plus tard l'escouade
dès qu'on est toujours là c'est devenu
une solution permanente pour transporter
les quelque vingt mille personnes qui
transitent matin et soir entre la rive
sud et montréal
environ 500 autobus qui congestionnent
les rues de montréal
le terminus centre-ville est bondé les
passagers de l'heure de pointe doivent
être disciplinés pour ne pas se marcher
sur les pieds
depuis 20 ans d'étude en étude on
cherche une solution
1992 une étude du cn propose un monorail
au coût de 197 millions projet abandonné
deux ans plus tard une firme allemande
aeg propose un très automatisée à 364
millions $ québec refuse ce projet un
sous ministre adjoint aux transports
écrit denier à bombardier l'opportunité
d'avoir accès à son propre marché
pourrait entacher sa réputation 1996
pour organiser le transport en commun
dans la grande région de montréal le
gouvernement du québec créé l' agence
métropolitaine de transport
dès 1999 la mt s'intéresse très léger
sur rail
il ne s'agit donc pas de dan ans de
projets mais bien
des études qui ont été faites avec la
collaboration de beaucoup de monde
ces études mène à une proposition de
tramo et de 640 millions $ illustré par
un modèle bombardier on fait donc un
tramway
non on fait d'autres études donc
nous allons continuer l'étude actuelle
je système léger sur rail à la suite de
deux appels d'offres la mt confie la
production d'une soixantaine de
documents d'étude au consortium équipe
slr métropolitain le projet grossit et
devient un métro de surface automatisé à
870 millions $ un système calqué sur le
skytrain de vancouver qui lie plus
vraiment un ces l'air même si on
continue de l'appeler ainsi leur mode
québec en fait une priorité le système
léger sur rail alors on va de l'avant
non jusqu'au prochain gouvernement
j'annonce aujourd'hui que le mode de
transport collectif choisi par le
gouvernement du québec pour le pont
champlain est un système léger sur rail
le slr québec accorde alors 28 millions
à limiter pour créer un bureau de projet
slr qui mènera d'autres études en plus
d'équipés slr métropolitain line 6a
confient plusieurs études à tecsult
devenu et comme dans celle ci rendue
publique par la presse l'an dernier et
voici le mandat de cette étude le mandat
se situe au niveau des études
préparatoires en amont des études
d'avant projet l'étude mentionne qu'il
faudra encore d'autres études
vous avez tout à fait raison richard
bergeron qui défend depuis longtemps le
train léger est exaspéré il ya 270 dans
le monde maintenant qu'ils ont des
salaires de tout sépare sauf que nous on
est peut-être plus facturer que tout ce
beau monde et ont peut-être commis une
erreur les 260 cas nous comme être à pau
parce que nous on est usé sérieusement
la plus récente étude prévoit un métro
de surface seront trajet de 18 km entre
le centre commercial dix30 et le centre
ville
le coût varie entre 1,4 et plus de 2
milliards de dollars selon le tracé mais
le nouveau ministre des transports
robert poésie est sceptique
ce soir à manchettes il n'y aura pas de
sitôt sur le nouveau pont champlain
québec mise sur des autos bleues c'est
peut être un jour des wagons on ne
recule pas complètement les accords avec
ce terme-là ce qu'il dit c'est qu'il n'a
pas assez d'informations pour prendre
cette décision alors le ministre demande
de poursuivre les études on a maintenant
consacrer plus de 40 millions pour et
suzie un train qui ne se fait toujours
pas la moitié de cette somme a été
dépensée
je suis un petit peu confuse même la
collègue libéral du ministre des
transports ne suis plus on fait un trait
coupat et comprenait moynier la décision
du choix du mode de transport sur le
pont champlain n'a pas été pris
mais avant la fin de cette nouvelle
ronde études touchant ce jeu très
heureux d'annoncer la conclusion d'une
entente commerciale entre le
gouvernement du québec et la caisse de
dépôt et placement du québec
miracle le projet de slr qui semblait
trop cher devient soudainement
réalisable rentables voire même
profitable grâce à la caisse de dépôt du
projet majeur pour la région
métropolitaine qui totalisent près de 5
milliards de la dette de dollars
d'investissements et il y aura deux
projets un trait du centre commercial 10
30 au centre ville et un autre train
entre le centre ville et l'aéroport qui
pourrait rejoindre le centre commercial
fairview à pointe claire
mais pendant que tous se réjouissent à
la caisse de dépôt un rapport jeanne ans
se trouve entre les mains des hauts
fonctionnaires du mtq
un rapport qui discrédite les prévisions
d'achalandage fait pour justifier le
trait sur le pont champlain
maintenant qu'il y a deux projets qui
s'étendrait du dix30 au centre
commercial fairview
le choix de la technologie devient
l'enjeu crucial une question à 5
milliards de dollars
françois pépin a passé l'essentiel de sa
carrière à la société de transport de
montréal en planification des transports
en commun comme s'il voulait acheter une
automobile
vous avez le choix entre la sma et vous
avez vu où cela rose ralenti les deux
vous avez toute une gamme donc il a
effectivement très bon urbain qui roule
sur une vue par zidane le tram-train qui
peut circuler à la fois sur une rue ou 6
sur une voie réservée aux trams trains
le clr de la mt est dans une toute autre
catégorie
c'est un métro de surface automatiser la
photo officielle utilisée depuis le
milieu des années 2000 dans plusieurs
des publications de limiter provident
son consultant équipe slr metropolit est
toujours le même train en pleut en verre
en crime italique remarqué ce sont les
mêmes voitures en arrière-plan
c'est une photo basé sur un train
bombardier le mark ii qui roule sur le
réseau skytrain de vancouver ont la
transplanter au milieu de l'autoroute 10
grâce à la magie d'un logiciel
ce dirigeant de translink la société
transport de vancouver l'a reconnu tout
de suite
itunes
ça semble beaucoup à notre marque 2 dans
un autre environnement parce que le
nôtre ne roule pas sur l'autoroute
oui ça ressemble beaucoup à nos voitures
les montres sont blanches c'est là sont
vertes seront baptisés prédécesseur
était au centre de la construction des
lignes expo et millenium snc lavalin
était aussi en projet et si c était le
leader du canada l'anglais
le skytrain de vancouver ils équivalent
du métro à montréal
un réseau de 68 km et 49 stations avec
une quatrième ligne actuellement en
construction
les contrats des lignes expo millénium
canada et evergreen ont tous été accordé
à bombardier et snc lavalin son flat
canada line qui est équipé de voitures
rotem
les trains sont entièrement automatique
il y panoramas sont spectaculaires les
coûts aussi 130 millions du kilomètre
pour le dernier prolongement d'intérêt
dont on nous parle c'est une structure
malgré son nom qui est assez lourde
c'est un train qui devraient circuler
dans des voies dédiées parfois surélevé
parfois sous terre
donc les infrastructures qu'on devra
construit pour permettre à cela de
circuler sont importantes
d'où le coût élevé l'autre des
immobilisations requises pour le
construire dans la dernière étude
commandée par la mt on donne même lit
mesure des voitures bombardier depuis
1999 la mt api des consultants pour
produire une centaine de documents sur
le slr dont 60 par équipes et celles
aire métropolitaine
un consortium formé de bombardier et snc
lavalin on leur a versé 8 millions trois
cent cinquante mille dollars
d'honoraires pour des études qui mettent
de l'avant leurs technologies
dans un courriel bon verdi nous a fait
valoir qu'au moins trois fournisseurs
pouvait répondre aux critères techniques
et qu'un comité d'experts valider la
neutralité des recommandations mais les
spécialistes que nous avons consultés
dénonce ce processus c'est une pratique
condamnable parce que sans seulement un
fournisseur ou une firme qui vont
participer à la réalisation du projet
éventuellement ou là comme manufacturier
du matériel ou la vente technologies et
à ce moment là cette firme là devraient
être exclues des études en amont c'est
certain que pour la population générale
il ya définitivement apparence de
conflit d'intérêts
richard bergeron est un partisan du
tram-train une technologie moins cher et
moins lourde que le métro de surface
automatisé bombardier en fabrique aussi
comme une expertise dans toutes les
technologies
comment se fait-il qu'ils ont tombé ça
pue cher on est illégitime et d'avoir
jusqu'à ce n'est point une préférence
mais l'or attendez vous pas que le
gouvernement pour nous imposer la
solution la plus chère totalement
déraisonnable au vu de la de
l'achalandage prévu d'un corrida s'il
vous plaît
ce qui justifie ou non un projet de
train et son ampleur c'est l'achalandage
en ce moment pendant l'heure la plus
achalandée de la période de pointe du
matin environ dix mille personnes
prennent l'autobus dans le corridor du
pont champlain
pourtant la mt nous prédit une vraie slr
manie de dix mille personnes
actuellement à 16 milles en 2021 et 25
mille passagers à l'heure de pointe en
2061 j'aime beaucoup la révision sur
2061 alors ça prend une boule de cristal
et j'ai quand même très excitant
responsable des analyses stratégiques
d'un planificateur principal des
transports de la région de montréal puis
jamais j'aurais osé faire une prédiction
sur un pareil horizons sauf à la blague
à laval on considère que c'est un énorme
succès que 13 % des automobilistes est
adopté le métro la mt prédit que
l'achalandage va plus que doubler avec
un salaire sur le pont champlain
une image très simple si on double
l'achalandage transports collectifs kak
soon as la moitié des usagers mais il y
aura plus personne en auto sur le pont
c'est très surprenant
nous avons obtenu ce rapport d'un comité
d'experts indépendants mandaté cet
automne par québec pour examiner les
prévisions de la mt leurs opinions ne
pourrait être plus clair
les chiffres présentés par la mt ne sont
pas à proprement des prévisions
d'achalandage
nous estimons que le scénario de
demandes optimiste mis de l'avant par
l'efmd n'est pas réalisable et que le
scénario conservateur et probablement
surévaluée
le rapport note que dans dix ans si l'on
suit la logique optimiste de la mt 88 %
des gens prendront le train il ne
restera plus que 12 % d'automobilistes
dans le vide aujourd'hui pour les
couples qui travaillent ils en ont
souvent des deux besoins d'automobiles
en fin de journée pour aller chercher
les enfants en garderie pour le ton
quand on dit que ça va doubler je
propose est question c'est est loufoque
et qu'en plus ce qu'ils travaillaient là
dessus prétendez y croire mon oeil
le modèle bombardier envisager peut
transporter de 35 à 53 mille personnes à
l'heure dans la configuration prévue par
la mt richard bergeron croit qu'on a
dopé les chiffres d'achalandage pour
exclure des trains plus léger et on a
besoin de 35000 de capacité donc ça nous
prend la technologie sky tué au hasard
ces bandits je crois que c'est ça le
rapport d'experts va dans le même sens
cette étude vise à entériner un choix
technologique les auteurs ressentent une
certaine perplexité en ce qui a trait
aux objectifs précis de la démarche de
modélisation entreprises par la mt on ne
peut qualifier cette démarche d'étude
d'achalandage est-ce qu'on a raison se
demander s'il n'y a pas eu du conte
flamand il présente la mt pour justifier
une solution
on a raison du repli des résultats et de
se poser des questions ça peut
effectivement amener un
surdimensionnement et en faire un
éléphant blanc
en mars 2013 le canada a conclu une
entente de libre-échange avec la corée
du sud ce qui donnera un peu profitent
de ces visites pour aller faire l'essai
du tout nouveaux trains bombardier dans
la ville de jiangyin un système
semblable à ce qui était envisagé à
montréal
fantastique n'est pas le mot employé par
les gens que nous avons rencontrés pour
décrire le projet lorsqu'il voit le
train et les contribuables de yongin ne
peuvent être qu'en colère sa première
junghee net une banlieue de séoul avec
ses 950 mille habitants ce n'est que la
12e ville de la corée du sud pourtant
une structure titanesque digne d'une
grande métropole surplombe la ville
et voici le très mise en service en
avril 2013
préférant attendre au début on pensait
que ce serait un métro mais le très
léger dit yang in là qu'une seule
voiture alors on pourrait dire que si
comme notre bus je ne m'étais boire et
éthiques un autobus qui coûtera aussi
cher qu'un mythe rond
le réseau fait 18 km et contestation les
stations ultra moderne et ultra
tranquille
ici les fonctionnaires se sont trompés
de 95% dans leurs prévisions
d'achalandage des allégations de
corruption ternissent le projet réalisé
en partenariat public privé entre la
ville et un consortium mené par
bombardier ton pour ce projet au total
un budget de plus de trois milliards et
demi de dollars sera dépensée sur 30 ans
3 milliards et demi c'est près de deux
fois le budget annuel total de la ville
nous explique ses deux conseillers
municipaux
c'est un gros hippopotame qui mange tout
nous en corée du sud c'était l'une des
premières expériences de ppp en
transport en commun
rencontre
après la crise monétaire de 1997 le
gouvernement à encourager les
partenariats public-privé en transport
cit group cit fait you mean a emboîté le
pas mais sans aucun expert pour la
conseiller très longue aussi le trait
religion guinot métro de séoul
il dessert aussi evans
l'un des plus grands parcs d'attractions
en asie
d'où le nom choisi pour cette ligne
everyone
malgré la publicité
il y avait moins de dix mille personnes
par jour à la mise en service
et même avec le rabais sur les
correspondances et la gratuité pour les
personnes âgées
il n'ya aujourd'hui que 20 mille
passagers en moyenne selon bombardier
or ces 180 3000 passagers par jour qui
avait prévu l'institut des transports de
corée l'équivalent de notre ministère
des transports souhaite un achalandage
tellement gonflée qu'on peut même dire
que ses comparses les incrétines maltais
c'est sur la base de cette prévision que
la ville a opté pour la technologie du
métro de surface automatisés aujourd'hui
ce sont les contribuables de yongin qui
font les frais de cette erreur
d'achalandage au mode ia ora
le canadien qui marche il était le
représentant commercial de bombardier en
corée du sud
il a convaincu l'ancien maire de yongin
de signer en 2004 une entente de revenu
minimum garanti pour les partenaires
privés qui finance un peu plus de 60% du
projet la ville devait donc garantir les
revenus correspondants à 145 mille
passagers par jour
et comme il y en avait 16 fois - en 2013
le budget de la ville aurait été
complètement siphonnés par le train dit
cet avocat qui a entrepris un recours en
justice pour que les responsables
rendent des comptes
toi m l'an dernier à la mise en service
du train le nombre de passagers a
atteint 5 6% de ses prévisions
alors la ville se diriger vers une perte
de 50 millions de la bad
madame à sendai
les constructions du très dure cinq ans
période au cours de laquelle le maire
lee jones moon reçoit des pots-de-vin de
certains sous-traitants
ce qui lui vaudra un an de prison
en 2010 le trait n'est pas mise en
service comme prévu parce que la
nouvelle administration a compris que
l'entente allait ruiner la ville mais un
contrat est un contrat tranche le
tribunal international d'arbitrage qui
condamne la ville à pays près de 900
millions de dollars pour dédommager les
partenaires privés le train est
finalement mise en service avec trois
ans de retard et dans tout ça en tête
rhône course à cette époque en guinée
n'avait pas d'argent
la ville a dû rompre invité un
investisseur privé et les intérêts
seulement côte 220 millions de dollars
ce sont les citoyens de new moon qui
sont victimes de la réduction des
budgets dans l'éducation la culture et
l'aide sociale
la bambino d'annaba et nous offrions le
chauffage dans les centrales l'auteur ou
les personnes âgées
cette année c'est coupé sur des wagons
on a aussi jolie le salaire des
fonctionnaires et réduisent leurs
avantages sociaux avec notre
collaboratrice en corée du sud qui me
nourrit nous avons tenté de comprendre
comment les élus se sont laissé
convaincre de faire ce train bombardier
une entreprise reconnue à travers le
monde sont venus ici dans une petite
ville ils ont travaillé avec des gens
qui ne connaissaient rien
l'équivalent de notre upac l'unité
spéciale dans le cade coréenne composé
de procureurs a examiné le projet de
yongin selon leur rapport
les trois fonctionnaires de l'institut
des transports qui ont fait des
prévisions erronées à 95% aux coulées
des informations confidentielles à
bombardier l'entreprise leur a offert
des cadeaux
il les a invités à visiter ses
installations au japon aux états unis et
au canada
ce sont ces fonctionnaires qui ont
recommandé un trait bombardier à
l'assemblée nationale de corée du sud
nous rencontrons le parlementaire de la
région jiangling chi minh qui
dès 2006 il a été l'un des premiers
policiers à enquêter sur le projet de
train et vers lane tottenham et à ses
seins ont lancé un projet dont on
n'avait pas besoin
à partir de ce moment j'ai eu des doutes
au solo grâce au talent des coûts d un
trajet d'une passe mélomanes par le
centre-ville avait une arnaque à la
limite de la légalité
c'est ce que je pense les allégations de
corruption contenues dans le rapport
dans lequel ne se limite pas aux
fonctionnaires de l'institut des
transports entre 2003 et 2005
bombardier a payé trois voyages au
canada à 37 personnes billets d'avion en
classe affaire golf tourisme et hôtels
luxueux 18 d'entre elles étaient membres
du conseil municipal de yongin et qui
mcbeal et et leur guide rien un
conseiller a déclaré aux enquêteurs que
certains membres de la délégation ont
préféré aller jouer au golf plutôt que
de monter à bord du skytrain à vancouver
la visite des chutes niagara étaient
aussi au programme
en chine ce n'est pas acceptable que
l'opérateur du projet est de faire ce
genre de voyage pour servir ses intérêts
l'unité spéciale d' enquête soutient
qu'on a découvert ces cadeaux et ses
voyages trop tard pour porter des
accusations
le délai prévu par la loi coréenne et de
cinq ans n'ont pas pu sanctionner qui
que ce soit pour les voyages parce que
le délai de prescription était écoulé
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il re
corruption
de plus bombardier aurait versé aux
canadiens qui mcbeal environ 2 millions
$ selon les enquêteurs qui soupçonne que
c'est un fonds clandestins de l'argent
qui aurait servi à faire du lobbying
auprès de fonctionnaires ou de
partenaires d'affaires pour d'autres
projets encore et kémag pelles a aussi
reçu de bombardier une prime de près de
5 millions de dollars après avoir obtenu
le contrat de yongin montant qu'il a
caché dans son compte en suisse ce qui
lui a valu deux ans de prison avec
sursis pour avoir éludé l'impôt est
détournée défend
lors de notre passage à séoul nous avons
retrouvé qui mac pile qui a accepté de
nous rencontrer le lendemain il annule
notre rencontre par texto nous le
rappelons voici quelques extraits de
conversations nous abordons la question
des voyages des élus diang hymne au
canada et dans le nord avio une fin
après sa condamnation qu'est mcgill a
été mise à la porte de bombardier
il a détourné près de 700 mille dollars
qui appartenait à son employeur avant de
nous raccrocher la ligne au nez il nous
réfère à son ancien patron serge buisson
nous avions déjà parlé à serge buisson
la veille c'est d'ailleurs lui qui a
organisé notre visite à bord du train à
eugene
de passage à montréal il a accepté de
nous faire part de sa vision du projet
c'est un beau système qui fonctionne but
qui donne rendement absolument
fantastique quand les fonctionnaires du
corian transportation institute
produisent des prévisions d'achalandage
pour la ville de yongin à 170 mille
passagers par jour vous savez que ce
n'est pas devant ces bruits et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a fait diminuer je ne
peux pas et je ne veux pas défendre les
gens qui ont fait détruire tout ce que
je souhaite dit au fait qu' on peut pas
exiger que ces gens là soient parfaits
dans leurs prédictions ils se sont
trompés
je me sens un être parfait se tromper de
95%
il me semble qu'une marge oui c'est vrai
il ya une énorme marge mais moi je peux
pas vous moi je peux pas vous expliquer
pourquoi
autrement que de vous dire qu'à l'époque
il y avait des prévisions qui étaient
optimistes avec un marché financier qui
allait bien avec la ddt mettez-vous
dépenses des conséquences assez
désastreux sur les finances de la ville
avec des conséquences désastreuses sur
wii cela c'est vrai que la ville aurait
pu économiser en faisant pas de système
après quatre mois d'achalandage
famélique
l'entente de revenu garanti a été
renégocié en juillet 2013
c'est maintenant un montant fixe qui
n'est plus basée sur le nombre de
passagers mais qui selon serge buisson
servirait à rembourser les frais des
partenaires privés on aurait négocié une
entente qui fait qu'il ne croulent plus
solide
il vient justement de remettre leurs
finances en ordre et non plus problème
les citoyens jiangyin n'ont pas fini de
payer en plus du milliard de fonds
publics déjà dépensé ils verseront cette
année environ 60 millions de dollars
il se sera la même chose pour toute la
durée du contrat de 30 ans près de la
moitié de cette somme va à payer le
contrat de gestion et d'entretien
ichigo qui gère et entretient le train
maintenant c'est encore mon parti c'est
incroyable histoire incroyable
serge buisson nie catégoriquement que
bombardier ait quoi que ce soit à voir
avec les déboires financiers qui ont
forcé la ville à couper dans les
programmes sociaux
c'est pas nous qui sommes arrivés là et
qui a bondi poids si on vous amène un
système et vos côtés 1.2 milliards de
dollars et puis pour vous pour vous le
payez vous aller couper la gorge de les
couper là et l'ol s'est pas c'est pas
nous qui avons fait ça c'est pas de
notre faute s'ils sont liés ou non ça
n'a rien à voir avec à tenir tout seul à
avoir avec est ce que les gens sont qu
on était capable de bien prévoir
l'avenir de leur ville et la réponse a
été non bon mais c'est quand même pas
notre faute à nous
pour lui offrir des voyages à des élus
et des fonctionnaires ce n'est pas de la
corruption
c'était pas un voyage d'agrément il ya
des besoins de convaincre ces gens là
que la technologie fonctionne bien en
quoi des visites des chutes niagara des
tournois de golf des hôtels luxueux 10
des vols en classe affaires en
croissance a convaincu une technologie
fonctionne mais pino ça ce sont donc des
d à côté d'un d'un voyage qui est
vraiment fait pour visiter les
installations
comme il est arrivé en corée qu'en 2010
serge buisson dit ignorer que bombardier
a fait des cadeaux aux fonctionnaires
qui ont fait les prévisions
d'achalandage si c'était de la
corruption et nous aurait poursuivi
ils rejettent catégoriquement toutes les
allégations contenues dans rapport d'
enquête
est ce que moi je fais fait qu'on n'a
pas fait de paiements illicites on n'a
pas payé d'impôts devraient toute cette
affaire a terni la réputation bombardier
en corée du sud comme génial de sont
affreux complètement ma salle de cours
lorsqu'on est en affaires il faut un
minimum de respect éthique de base
il faut que tout le monde sache la
vérité sache comment une compagnie très
respectée s'est comporté ici on veut une
entente est plus juste à l'aplomb elle
tarde à venir
il rien de caché dans ce qu'on a fait il
ya peut-être des frustrations mais bon
sauf si les gens veulent savoir et en
parler je suis encore prêt au cours de
l'entrevue
serge buisson fait des déclarations
étonnantes pensez vous que l'achalandage
de de 3000 personnes à l'heure de pointe
ça justifie une technologie des
infrastructures aussi imposante à yongin
n'ont sûrement pas pour l'instant mais
pour le moment est ce que c'est trop
fort d'applis un éléphant emblème
simpson je sais pas moi j'ai que je sais
c'est que là chaque fois que je vois des
systèmes de transport au début ils ont
l'air bien ont l'air tout seul au milieu
de nulle part et 10 ans après c'est
plein c'est complètement construits
c'est quoi l'avantagé d'un pipi quand le
public se retrouve finalement à éponger
à semer la plupart des et des risques en
fait j'en sais rien - personnellement je
crois pas je crois que c'est trop
compliqué je sais pas comment un ppp
peut fonctionner dans des projets
complexes et dans des choses qui
demandent des prévisions sont tellement
longues périodes
pourtant dans le communiqué fleuri de
bombardier qui félicite la ville de
yongin pour l'inauguration de la
volaille serge buisson déclare que le
projet a été mené à bien par un
partenariat public-privé révolutionnaire
à yongin c'est une révolution dont on se
serait bien passé s'ils ont continué à
verser de l'eau dans un seau percé un
vrai gaspillage qui ne sert à rien et
pas durer trente ans plus tôt à mon sens
bien
l'idée paraît séduisante retrouvé une
fierté dans la réussite de grands
projets cette fierté que je recherche le
premier but du québec que l'offre qu'on
est dans la métropole ou dans nos
grandes villes qu'on ait eu à rougir de
rien par rapport à ce qui se fait
ailleurs dans le monde je pense que la
cour se donne les moyens
transformer une dépense en profite tout
en améliorant le transport en commun
la caisse de dépôt et placement du
québec se donne le droit de refuser les
projets slr après un examen approfondi
de leur rentabilité
mais son pdg semble déjà conquis chaque
fois que vous avez monté à bord d'une
système de transport géré par la caisse
vous serez en train de consolider votre
retraite
les québécois pourront développer un
excellent arrêt les infrastructures dont
ils ont besoin urgemment aujourd'hui
tout en préparant leur retrait de demain
un cercle vertueux
depuis 1999
snc lavalin et bombardier ont fortement
participé aux études de la mp qui ont
mis de l'avant le métro de surface
automatisés le super japon les gens de
la mt sont intelligents le gouvernement
du québec de superviser leur travail oui
oui pourquoi ils font la promotion d'un
skytrain pendant des années parce qu'on
leur a passé la commande politique
d'étudier le sky tree la conclusion du
rapport d'experts indépendants mandaté
par québec est accablante les prévisions
issus de la démarche adoptée par la mt
ne sont pas suffisantes pour alimenter
la réflexion et supporter le choix d'un
mode de transport en commun spécifique
dans lynx du futur pont champlain
au québec un on a tendance à se
précipiter vers la solution sans prendre
le temps de regarder vrai véritablement
le besoin
la mt a perdu son rôle de maître
d'oeuvre du projet slr et a refusé nous
accorder une entrevue
c'est maintenant la caisse qui va mener
le projet et à s'engager le faire dans
les règles de l'art nous avons tous les
intérêts commerciaux pour pour avoir une
un processus d'appel d'offres très
robuste ça c'est l'objectif et une
processus de paix encore très
transparente
mais l'idée d'implanter à montréal la
même technologie qu'à vancouver et yang
il semble plus vivant que jamais c'est
ma nouvelle c'est bon pour les gens de
vancouver avec le skytrain pourquoi pas
nous même si la canada line de vancouver
est un projet en ppp c'est quand même
les contribuables qui ont financé plus
de la moitié du projet de 2 milliards la
personne qui était responsable du
développement et les apparitions de la
société qui te tient le canada cette
personne travaille à l'accueil semaine à
la caisse vient d'embaucher jean-marc à
rebours qui dirigeait les opérations de
snc lavalin pour la construction de la
canada line à vancouver la mt il avait
recruté en 2013 pour diriger le bureau
de projet et c'est l'air à montréal
il avait quitté ses fonctions chez snc
lavalin au nom paravent ya beaucoup de
travaux qui ont déjà été faites par les
agences gouvernementales et par la mt
notamment nous allons utiliser les
données qui existe des gens et nous
allons les compléter au besoin pour
avoir un portrait aussi précis que
possible
bombardier la seule entreprise qui
fabrique des trains urbains dans
laquelle la caisse de dépôt à une
participation directe comme snc lavalin
bombardier ni que d'avoir participé aux
études de la mt procure un avantage des
deux entreprises ont refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue mais font valoir
que celle amt qui a dicté les choix
technologiques et que des mesures ont
été mises en place afin d'éviter les
conflits d'intérêt
depuis l'an dernier le président de
bombardier pierre beaudoin s'est inscrit
au registre des lobbyistes notamment
auprès du cabinet du premier ministre
pour l'attribution d'un contrat
autrement que dans le cadre d'un appel
d'offres public pour le projet slr sur
le nouveau pont sur le saint laurent
faut revenir à la base ici ce qu'on veut
c'est améliorer le transport on veut
favoriser le transport en commun
et est ce que ce projet est vraiment
est ce que c'est vraiment l'objectif
ultime qu'on poursuit c'est maintenant
la caisse de dépôt et au gouvernement du
québec de prouver que l'intérêt public
peut l'emporter sur l'intérêt de
certaines entreprises on choisira une
technologie en fonction de nos besoins
réels et un tracé vraiment pensé pour
les usagers du transport en commun